for more than a decade Tony Malakian has
painted some of Indonesia's best known
politicians for National newspapers and
magazines he's known for his
unflattering depictions of political
Elite including the president I can draw
and I have a perspected about human
rights in Indonesia so I just
yeah I show my feelings my expression my
speech as a freedom as my human rights
feelings yeah just show it with
drawings cartoon caricature but work
like this could land the artist in
trouble in coming years
under the new criminal code ratified
earlier this month anyone perceived to
be insulting the president vice
president or a state institution could
be imprisoned for three years or longer
if the offense is on a digital platform
I think this is you know a serious turn
towards the Dark Side of Indonesian
politics which is an authoritarian turn
so we have to to think how to roll back
how to push back uh this uh this uh
maneuver many fear critical reporting
will be construed as an insult
some activists journalists and political
commentators have raised concerns the
vague wording of the law might
contribute to selective enforcement and
create a climate of fear as it's unclear
what can and cannot be said
the ministry of Law and human rights
says the government welcomes criticism
and has promised to clarify
uncertainties about the hundreds of
articles in the code during what it
calls a socialization period
under the law people will need
permission before organizing a
demonstration or risk six months behind
bars journalists can also be jailed for
Distributing news that's considered
unverified exaggerated or incomplete
some human rights lawyers are planning
to challenge the law the exercise of a
freedom of expression which is which is
also critics to our government whether
it's it's bad performances its bad
services and so on which also done by
the very Grassroots people in Indonesia
even if attempts to change the code are
unsuccessful Tony says he won't stop
speaking out his latest comic shows how
those who challenge the criminal code
may become its victims Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera Jakarta